hello everyone happy Saturday morning
thanks for making it hopefully you're
not too hungover and everyone's Brighton
awake thanks for coming to my talk how
rocket science can help build your app
and boy that seems a little strange
rocket science is a very abuse term I'm
not even a huge fan of it but it got you
guys here that's great so Who am I some
of we're a few different hats I'm a NASA
JPL mission architect I typically live
in the part of JPL where we come up with
missions the very beginning I've worked
on several dozen concepts a few of my
own though right now I'm taking a break
to finish my PhD down the road at Wash U
and high-energy physics some people know
me as a love expert a little bit strange
but they say those who can't do teach
and that's what my girlfriend thinks as
well when I started accompanying dinaya
around an algorithm that can actually
predict your love life and we'll get to
that a little bit later and the thread
that unites all of these is that if I
had to call myself anything it's more of
a systems theorists so is it a
sociological system economic system
mechanical physical computer whatever I
like thinking about how complex things
work now few brief caveats before I
begin all the views expressed here today
are mine they are opinions they very
well may be completely wrong but most
importantly they do not reflect NASA or
caltech JPL I'm here on behalf of nya
what you'll end up also seeing as a lot
of text on slides which is therefore
contacts you can listen to the words
instead of being confused over some of
the things that i right and again this
is Saturday morning and it is a
management theory talk so buckle up
we're in for a wild ride okay so how to
begin let's think about two different
organizations they have two different
purposes two different goals customers
stakeholders revenue streams one is
google + 1 is JPL so what are like some
of the differences that immediately come
to mind the first one for me is
adversity to risk
we can think of Google and I'm not
necessarily a huge fan of Google but
really their products and you have
things like Google+ Google glasses that
have been like programmatic failures
meaning that the budgets the schedules
can close with respect to the
development cycle or and then you have
operational failures like Google Plus
which you build it it's deployed and
then it just doesn't really work out
within that market but it doesn't really
matter to Google because hey what other
alternatives are out there so long as
you are in the market you've established
yourself there and that is their purpose
so adversity to the risk is a pretty not
high on the priority of Google's agenda
on the other hand you have NASA or
caltech JPL and if you loo if you lose a
500 million dollar two billion dollar
mission you have to go back to Congress
and ask for that money and they won't
probably not give it to you and we have
is mars polar lander which had a
deployment failure of its legs before it
landed near the North Pole of Mars the
legs unfurled about tens of meters above
the surface the accelerometer said oh we
landed and it cut the entry engine so
then it hit the surface and everything
broke and that was that and we were able
to do it after a decade or so through a
different cycle of missions but another
thing that comes is from the history of
the organizations and that is ideology
if you think of Silicon Valley the 1970s
the concept of individuality a personal
freedom that we can have these natural
self-organizing systems these will be
ultimately what's most efficient or so
that ideology says but the other hand
you have NASA which if you think about
it you go back to World War two the Cold
War you have these systems these human
systems that are designed to fight in
conflict to prepare for conflict and
they are highly critical and because of
that you have hierarchies and that's
what NASA has inherited and the last one
that can think of the that's superficial
but still deep in a sense is the
system's complexity if you're making a
Google product and it's a coup it's a
google project for the next set of
software you have interfaces within the
project and then you also have two
interfaces beyond the project and these
are software interfaces but
also user experience interfaces so you
can maintain uniformity across go Google
products but if you think of spacecraft
that NASA builds they are entities a
complete onto themselves you have
multiple different subsystems you have
the telecommunications thermal
management science instruments they own
they have their own hardware they have
their own software and they all have to
interface and the variability of this
high dimensionality leads to
significantly more complexity for any
one product so how does NASA do things
and how can that be applied to software
development and that's what I'm here to
talk about I myself started ania this
sort of software app company and I
applied what I would say are relatively
controversial methods is you'll be
seeing to building software and they
worked very well but the ultimate thesis
of this talk is that there is no silver
bullet for how to develop and your
project so how does NASA do things so
you can see here there are many phases
you have this pre phase a of phase a
phase B faci phase d e and F rates F and
you'll see all these different triangles
and what those triangles are are these
very large reviews where you get
together people on the team external
experts and you sit together for a day
or even up to a week to go over
everything that you have done and to
make sure that everything is good and if
the reviewers which are not necessarily
on your team say you haven't done a good
job you have homework to do everything
stops until it's complete the reviewers
are satisfied and then you can continue
but let's go into a little bit more
detail so for the agile folks out there
you would be familiar with the scrum and
that's sort of what we do in this a pre
phase a which is we think of the problem
the mission goal for a space mission and
just think of like how does this even
make sense right after that we think of
does the answer that we came up with in
pre phase eight actually makes sense and
that's amazing phase B is the next step
of now that we understand what
the mission will look like how will the
project really look like in addition to
some of the other technical open
technical questions phase C and D is
really when you start building things
and I mix them together because the
truth is NASA's found out as in this
mature you guys all do is you're
building you test and the last step for
people and ops it's gulp because you
finally deploy it and you hope that
everything works well if you saw that it
looks a little scary maybe because it
looks like a waterfall and you know it's
i would say that things are all about
words and people use terms like agile or
waterfall and as far as I'm concerned
they're sort of buzzwords and the truth
is of course that there is sort of an
agile working group and they have a
concept for how agile design works how
the program works now no implementation
is perfect these are sort of like
platonic ideals in a sense you're never
going to have a true pure implementation
of it every project is different now for
sort of explaining how NASA goes to
these different phases I'll use the
example of a Uranus probe thank you for
laughing no one laughs about it at work
and I just kind of feel awkward for
laughing inside and this is a fictional
example but I have worked on two
different concepts of this mission and
the general ideas you send a spacecraft
out there that deploys a probe and the
probe enters Uranus and they tries to
take measurements of the upper
atmosphere to understand well how is it
composed what is the structure the
temperature of the density the
composition of clouds and whatnot so pre
phase a where we're thinking about this
probe you start off with like what are
the actual key objectives what do you
want to accomplish and that sort of
characterized by what I had up in the
last slide characterized the upper
atmosphere then come what comes next is
the high-level requirements so what do
you need for the project to succeed
which is building the thing and
deploying the thing and operating the
thing and then also the mission itself
so to get like actual mission success
that you've got the right science back
and then when you have all these
different requirements we all know
there's
more than one way to come up with a
solution or a correct solution but I
would argue there it tends to be a best
solution and what we do is we have these
trade studies where we look at this wide
parameter space of potential solutions
to figure out what is what we think is
best so you know there's a lot of words
up there but i'm just going to speak
very generally to them this is for like
the details so become of these
requirements that the probe must do
these certain things to make sure that
we got the correct science back we must
get the data back to earth because
otherwise why did he send anything out
there and there's a programmatic
requirement we need to launch this thing
by 2021 otherwise we miss our launch
window to Uranus and we'll have to wait
over a decade for the next opportunity
and what we start to do is we build
what's called a science traceability
matrix and I don't have a laser pointers
I'm just going to run so we have high
level science schools so here is we want
to figure out the noble gas abundances
so your argon helium and we have to do a
specific measurement with respect to
what we want from these noble gases and
to do that we'll need an instrument
which is a mass spectrometer and then
the functional requirement is the probe
needs to reach this steep within the
atmosphere to be able to do so so we've
done is we've connected the requirements
to the purpose of why we're doing this
whole thing trade studies so okay well
there is more than one way to do it so
we can do an orbiter mission or a flyby
which is the parent spacecraft which
communicates to the probe because once
you start sending something into the
atmosphere Uranus good luck trying to
close a radio link so we can either have
it or bit and circle around the planet
which means you have to carry a lot more
propulsion or you're just going to end
up flying by it and that's probably
cheaper but maybe you'll lose some of
the radio link bit with a probe so
there's trade-offs and there's a few
different ones and when we have all
these different trades some of them are
independent some of them are dependent
and you get this sort of the
funny-looking chart it's kind of hard to
read the title but it's relative science
value versus cost with risk indicator
and you have funny different colors and
so each of these boxes represents a
different way to do the mission and we
can see that some are more
offensive and we can see this sort of
like a deflection point we would say
that maybe that is the maximum and this
the optimal in this case so it depends
on the metrics of the mission but it
would be things like parts failure or
the chances of establishing a link cost
is an extra programmatic risk as well so
if you can't close n specific costs so
it really does vary but for a lot of it
is looking at things that can fail and
the probabilities of failure based on
past experience and then some modeling
so in pre phase a oh sorry so how can
this be effective because you're
starting to plan a lot of really
complicated things when like you don't
really have anything when we're not
there we don't actually know a lot of
the details about Uranus because and
that's another one of the risk we don't
know much about the upper atmosphere
because only one mission is actually
gone there which is the wager too so you
get everyone that's sort of an expert
has some experience into the same room
so people from the project managers the
scientists to people on the telecom side
thermal management power systems and you
just think of all of the different ways
to do it in a very sort of like open
brainstorm e way and you come up with
how this trade space is populated people
go and do their homework and then they
fill out charts like the lease on the
last slide so at the end of phase a you
think you have sort of a way that this
might make sense and you have it
reviewed and it's the mission concept
review and you gave a few dozen people
in the room and that's for nasa says
okay we think we're going to spend 500
million dollars on this or two billion
or whatever next is okay well does the
thing that we think makes sense actually
makes sense because you haven't thought
it out to too much yet so you have to
identify the critical systems and then
the team without which the mission will
not happen next is okay well if you now
know these critical systems you can know
a little bit more have a little bit more
granularity of the requirements that
flow from them and we have those
requirements you can begin to further
define the mission like the technical
aspect and then the project aspect as
well where you can put together sort of
a labor schedule a budget and that'll
give you an idea of how things will end
up really work
detail so for the critical systems the
Uranus probe will have the probes
thermal protection system because it
gets pretty hot when you start
descending it you know many kilometres
second into an atmosphere the probe
instruments to give you the science here
I'm going to say that we couldn't find a
way to make it close within the budget
unless we used an old radio so that's a
critical system because we can't fulfill
the budget otherwise and then also the
systems engineering complexity well
that's not a system but you know what
it's really important that we make sure
that everything else is as simple as
possible if it's not critical and
everyone who is a technical engineer
needs to be informed of that from that
we get more requirements so for instance
from the radio requirement we have to
see that well this is old hardware and
we're building most other things new for
various reasons maybe parts availability
so we have to make sure that those
interfaces are well defined and as soon
as they're connected they know how to
talk to one another and then say another
thing that we're getting is a free
donated instrument from the french space
agency can us which is a nephelometer it
measures the density of clouds and this
must be delivered by such and such state
so we can integrate it technically now
because of arms regulation everything
going to space even if its civilian is
technically under arms that's how the US
government defines it so we have to get
our lawyers and groom figure out how
what we have to do for that that's a
programmatic requirement so from that we
can put together a Gantt chart figure
out what's in the critical path things
on the critical path we can consider d
scoping and having requirements for D
scopes we can get a wbs we can figure
out what the labor is and put together a
pretty accurate budget how everything
will burn down okay you have more
reviews and then when everyone is happy
you continue phase B so let's can we
actually make this happen how is it
going to work out so we start designing
things we then check for heritage so
that would be like the radio in this
example we check for critical
technologies so say for instance that
nephelometer that the French are making
its like a new instrument all together
it's using a new technology we have to
make sure that all the technology is
mature tested and ready within like
tori in flight lake setting before we
are ready to even consider putting this
on the mission and if it's not we have
to cut it and then we move on and one of
the biggest reviews is this preliminary
design review so that happens before you
start like cutting stuff up in the shop
or writing code and this could be a week
long ordeal phase c/d so this is you
know building things and making sure
they work so there's like two mantras of
JPL and one of them is in every review
you really have to say that you're
improve that you're doing this which is
test as you build build as you test so
as you're building things you're testing
them at a component level and then you
integrate to the subsystem level and
then you test again with everything
they're all the ways you tested it
before in new ways as well and then
integrated the system level and so on
and so on and you're continually testing
as you go and how does this end up
looking organizationally and so when you
have big missions like the two billion
dollar Mars Science Laboratory that
curiosity that was employing several
thousand people at JPL simultaneously
it's a lot of people and it's a big
organization so this is obviously a
simplification you have the management
up at the top you have the project
scientist project systems engineer in
the project manager all with the
different responsibilities i'll be going
over in the denial below them are teams
of systems engineers that makes sure
that all the specific technical groups
the radios the thermal control the power
systems they're all all the things that
they're doing they're using uniform
language that the system model that they
are working off of is the same the
interfaces are uniformly understood as
progress continues and then you have
that specific technical leads and all
the different sub system or component
teams and then when you start to
actually finish some of the subsystems
and components the team's merge and they
begin testing together and it was a job
of the systems engineers above them to
work with them beforehand to get a
systems test integration plan for when
they continue until eventually you have
the complete flight system and then the
next step is well when you have the
flight system together you test as you
fly and then you flies you test
meaning that all the systems tests that
you do are exactly what's going to be
happening in the operational environment
of the spacecraft and including the off
nominal conditions like what happens if
this thrust correction maneuver fails
and things like that and then because
you've tested that way when you come up
with your operations plan it should be
written based on how you did your
testing plan so a big part of even doing
the test plan is to plan operations well
well in advance so in phase a we're in a
right do a lot of my work I'm writing
like minute by minute things of how
we're taking pictures on or around a
common so again a lot of words up here
but I'm going to draw just a quick
attention to the launch vehicle
integration and launched environment so
when we think of a space mission while
boy it's in space and it does Spacey
things but it has to live on the ground
and it has to be on a launch vehicle
before that even happens which means you
have to test putting it on or rocket
even before you have a rock if you have
to have all that hardware in place you
have to know how you're going to be
managing the spacecraft computer and
radio because they'll have to be off you
have to make sure that everything there
will work and then again you are going
to be making a phenomenal test to figure
out how the system behaves and how the
various components behave in different
environments that you will not be
happening as planned and from there you
do contingency planning and further
testing and you just keep doing that
until you run out of time or money and I
mean phase c/d has a lot of reviews
pretty much every integration and you
get everyone all the different technical
leads in a room with management with the
systems engineers and everything is very
deeply scrutinized phase ii is gulp and
you launch but even when you launch
you're actually still testing all the
things you're going to be doing in
flight you don't stop people are still
testing code and testing spacecraft
maneuvers critical takeaways so I would
argue that yes you actually can plan
every step and even if you can't plan it
exactly you can at least plan how you
will plan it and a part of doing that is
writing the technical and programmatic
requirements again not just on the
technical things but of how the entire
team will work together making sure
there is a consistent set of goals
language and everyones using justify
requirements so make sure there's a
reason they're there which means
everyone's going to be looking at them
who's a technical lead maybe as long as
they're sharing an interface and then
also having a way to make sure that what
you're building can even be tested so
I've seen one system in specific they
came up with requirements but they
didn't have a good way of testing it and
then it didn't pass reviews and actually
because of that the system was sent back
into development and from all these
requirements embedding them you can get
labor schedule and budget and they
actually end up being very accurate I
would say but what's really important is
you need a formal system of
communication such that everyone is
using the same language when they're
working together time to bring things a
little bit down to earth so in 2014 as a
result of a breakup I came up with an
algorithm that can predict your love
life it was her idea not mine I have
some philosophical opposition to it but
hey you know what it's I think it's very
helpful for some people it's actually
really cool results I suggest all of you
guys to use it so people come in so just
to give you an idea of Nanaia people
come in you do sort of a questionnaire
and you hit submit and runs the
algorithm and then you get a six page
report n do I'm so it's not like online
dating it's actually doing a lot of like
calculations in the back in those
calculations if you're really curious
they're over viewed in this archive
paper I wrote at the very clickbait
titles should I break up with my
girlfriend will I find another you know
what a media covered it because it's a
very nice title so so again it says the
algorithm it has a lot of math in it but
the interesting thing is with every new
user that comes the data goes into the
database so in the next user comes and
you're saying oh I'm trying to look for
women and st. Louis it starts pulling
the women around st. Louis to figure out
what is the distribution of values
personality that would match what you're
looking for so every new person that
comes improves the fidelity of the model
so again this is in my mind this isn't a
saw
offer project this is a space mission so
I have a mission provide an easy-to-use
online service offering algorithmically
generated personalized predictions for
users romantic and social life so for
people who've done like some MBA ish
classes people will say oh the mission
goal or statement is very important and
i truly believe it actually is even if
nothing else and that mba program would
be now so the important part of this is
it's so much specific the kind of like
characterized the upper atmosphere of
Uranus but there's a lot of ways to do
it so you know well how are we going to
do this so we have a pre phase a and you
know there's project constraints like a
NASA you know project I have you know no
data and this is essentially a big data
product no users know sort of like
publicity or marketing that's not my
wheelhouse I have a small team of
friends and night have a little bit of
money and the thing that makes this more
like a space mission in my mind is this
is my money I'm currently a grad student
this is mission critical that I I need
us to work so i am going to be planning
the hell out of this so again a lot of
words but I sort of think of the very
high level like how can we satisfy these
requirements and not all of these again
are technical so for instance when I
want users and i know i'm not going to
really be good at the whole media
wrangling thing i want to launch this
thing around valentine's day because i
think that's when i'll be able to get
the most attention so that is a big
programmatic requirement and if i didn't
sort of have that the project as a whole
may not have been successful so from
that we get a sense of trade studies all
the different ways to solve this and
again there's a bunch of them just just
the show but i'm going to focus on one
specific problem which is I think one of
the fundamental problem of this consumer
product in a big data product which is I
need data coming in so I can run the
algorithm but people aren't going to
come in unless they can get the product
of the algorithm so it's a chicken and
egg problem and I have to think of all
the different ways of solving it now
just sort of the very high level but
then
way to implement the solution so and
it's worth mentioning so GTL is a very
big organization this is just a few
people you'll see these three people and
a lot of these slides the systems
engineer the scientists the management
which I where all of those hats so I was
having a very complicated conversation
with myself spit of the very sort of you
know the pre phase a level how am I even
going to get this data from users what
am I going to have to show and the
management's going to be thinking of all
these are the programmatic requirements
I am defending these in the design of
all the other requirements the scientist
is saying well this is the data that I
need and I'm going to make sure that I
get it and then the systems engineer
their job is to sort of reconcile it to
rationalize what makes a proper solution
to this and from this I and I got sort
of the general idea of how everything
will flow we have this Nanaia block so
i'm going to have one launch here one
which is block one and that's just
personality testing because people like
personality testing it's not the
algorithm but it gives me what I need
for the algorithm to run so the very
basic level of demographic data and
personality data block 2 is sort of a
limited release of the algorithm so it's
not predicting whether or not two people
should stay together because I want to
do a lot of testing on that before it's
released for like very like you know
moral ethical reasons but it gives some
people idea of like when you'll find
love the best groups to find love in how
you can change your social interactions
to maximize those odds so it's still
interesting data and this gives me a lot
of the better information that really
lets me validate the full algorithm for
block three and just so you know block 1
was launched January 15 and blocked who
was launched rate for Valentine's Day
this year so then we go into Phase II of
block 1 so again the personality testing
and we have now we have the UI UX
engineer front-end management's project
quote-unquote scientists and the systems
now again we have the three people from
before and they're trying to make sure
that all those requirements they have
the very high level are being met while
the people the the front end dev and the
UI UX and the sort of the technical side
they're finding ways of really
fulfilling those require
and coming up with newer lower level
requirements and whenever the systems
engineer and the managers ever meet with
anyone else on the technical side it
really is supposed to be an exercise in
humility and this is fundamental for the
perspective of team trust of look I know
this is what I want but I'm probably
pretty stupid so tell me how I'm wrong
and I'm sure there's still a better way
and so when that's reported up state of
the systems engineer then they have to
meet with all the other technical leads
to make sure okay this is what so-and-so
told me does that make sense and then
the systems engineer tries to
rationalize between what everyone's been
saying okay now we enter into phase v we
come up with those lower level
requirements so how are we going to
build this so the front end dev in the
UI UX they're still going on to the next
step of actually putting together like
wireframes sort of like a template some
code maybe Django models and then the
systems entries making sure is there
sort of like starting to like put these
things together in their minds or like
is mock-ups as prototypes they're like
these are fulfilling the technical
requirement that they themselves came up
with and the project managers looking at
the calendar and the budget making sure
like okay progress is fine and you end
up getting and this is what we have for
Nanaia and I don't know who else really
does does this by talked to a few dev
friends and other people who are doing
some of the external work for me and
they haven't seen like this level of
requirements with like systems test
plans and component test plans
validation plans whatnot for what was a
very small project but this is what we
were able to produce out of all of this
and this was like in my meetings with
various different people trying to make
sure what made sense and then we
reviewed at all of us together before
ever continuing and then we actually got
to building and now everyone comes
together so front ends really doing this
because this is about how we're getting
data from users and so they're building
the website UI UX is making sure that ok
what you're a building satisfies the
requirements that I laid out because I'm
now looking at it and I'm testing it the
back end dev is making sure though all
those form fields is getting the data
into the database the scientist is
making sure everything that's coming
into the database from those forms
actually satisfies the science
requirements and then the systems
engineer who's
really intermediating between everything
is just tearing their hair out normally
there's plenty of systems engineers and
then the manager is again looking at the
calendar in the budget so okay we launch
block one we have our phase ii yay it's
a success we have enough users that we
can put together the next step which is
a partial algorithm but now we need to
get a lot more data from people because
we're using the algorithm rather than
doing personality testing and so we have
the front end in the UI UX they have to
do a completely different front page or
the sorry I just page in general and
that's we knew that from before but so
how will this be changing from what we
have the scientists is going over making
sure that all the new data coming in is
exactly what we need for the algorithm
back end dev is making sure that okay do
we have to change any of the models or
database structure and there again all
meeting over this about the users
putting in data and making sure that
they are happy to put in data then
ultimately the result the report that
they see is worth the time emotionally
that the user is put into it so they can
be happy even if the results are really
sad and so that's kind of how things
worked for that one specific problem and
you know in when we got to that block to
phase a and we reviewed and we're like
okay there's a bunch of things need to
change but we actually ready knew that
from the beginning and the things that
added up changing really weren't severe
in scope and they had minimal
programmatic impact so I would say the
whole deny experiment of applying this
sort of waterfall ish approach and I
don't think it really is because of how
much there is that sort of roving
systems engineers was a bit of as I
think a success given how limited the
resources were we launched blocked one
again two years ago block to this year
and then we had over 200,000 users since
Valentine's Day and I'm the one doing
the marketing and I'm doing I PhD and
I'm still supporting some JPL stuff so
boy you know i i'm very satisfied with
how things worked and what we ever we do
in the future or code base is ready to
go because we have planned for
everything down the line for other
products products as well so of course
there's failure and that
I think the most important thing out of
everything so the point is we planned
our failures so we said okay we're not
going to close on our budget we know
we're not but maybe we'll be good maybe
we'll have some things ahead of schedule
we didn't get to everything and the
things that were not on the critical
path and we saw we're not going to get
to and we had specific milestones plan
we said okay drop this don't think about
it and some of the devs were actually
kind of upset and I was kind of upset
about some but it's about the mission
success bottom line and then operational
success I woke up the second day after
launch to find out that a lot of people
in Brazil were using this accessing like
who knows how many database connections
that we just hadn't planned for because
we didn't think anyone was really going
to use it we said if this ever happened
we should just party and forget about it
so we knew about it we thought about him
just said whatever and while what
happened was we sort of predicted and we
fixed it but again it's an operational
failure that we sort of planned around
and the plan was to not care so so okay
people might III don't know I've talked
to a few people about this which is why
i was giving this talk where people are
very skeptical about how i went about
the development and there's criticisms
so i like how can you really plan for
things in advance and especially for
others who aren't doing necessarily
consumer product you have specific
business customers i understand that you
know customers minds change so of course
this what i did isn't for everyone it's
about what can we learn from it and
apply it elsewhere what are the sort of
like rules of thumb and really in my
mind is that again there's no silver
bullet I don't think the concept of the
self-forming organic teams is
necessarily a good idea I don't think
what I did was necessarily good idea it
is highly contextual based on your
team's experience so that's the social
dynamics of the various constraints they
have criticality so there I don't think
there was any real single optimal
framework but maybe there was a
framework of frameworks and when I was
thinking about this and I did a little
bit of research to say okay well am I
totally crazy there's actually some
folks that wrote about it in a book
balancing agility and discipline a guy
two per plot to the perplexed
by bill them and Turner and I read
through some of it was I thought a
pretty good read of this so we can think
of just three high-level parameters to
risk criticality and complexity whenever
you have a lot more of them you need to
have that hierarchy and planning to make
sure that you satisfy that project or
mission goal and on the other hand if
you don't have these having teams that
sort of figure out for themselves on a
technical level what makes sense ends up
maybe working out better unmuting that
mission goal optimally so what the hell
is the point of this hierarchy anyway
then because I don't necessarily think
it's risk criticality or complexity I
personally believe it's about the flow
of information on if anyone recognize
foucault at the bottom who may disagree
with uh sorry but this I would say this
applies to projects and development
which is if you're going to have
hierarchy and people that have like
management authorities that includes
technical lead systems engineers or you
know the very highest level managers
it's about having a consistent flow of
information that is universal across the
team so that everyone knows how to speak
and it is the role of authority and
power to mandate and fix the concept of
language so oh gosh this is a lot of
words and this is for posterity and you
can read it now but like you know the
you know i would say rule one of like if
you're going to have a project there's
no one correct answer and you really i
think have to feel that and believe that
in your hearts the second role is is I
think it is up to the people who come up
with the idea and who see it out forward
so it would be for the management but
leadership in general that's technical
leads as well in systems engineers to
come up with a high level goals and
requirements and then work with the
technical leads to see how the lower
level requirements work out and then as
the project continues the leadership so
again the technical leads not just like
you know the code monkey devs badger I'm
sorry the systems engineer is the
management to really make sense of
progress in to either change the
requirements while working with all the
folks below them the hierarchy or to
adjust the
flow of resources and you know that's
about it please do use and share in the
nya right now I'm sort of thinking of a
block two and a half there's a few other
funny things i'll be doing as soon as i
finish my PhD I do like a little bit of
theory so I think I can ply quantum
field theory to you know romance and
human relationships we'll see about that
one and then I want to be able to some
lovely sociology studies with the data
we have coming in and I'll be happy to
take any questions thank you for coming
so i will say that as a function of your
oh yes thank you so the question was you
know one of the most important things to
a successful organization is the ability
to pivot when things may not be working
as expected and is it possible that
you're planning so much in advance that
you still retain the ability to pivot
and again I think the two parts that
question one it's a function of your
team so if you have at the very high
level people who have that foresight of
the potential issues you can run into
and again this the whole point of
pivoting an organizational level is the
programmatic risk it's not the technical
risk so can you plan out and when you do
when you are planning out can you
broaden your scope so in your
brainstorming sessions or whatever not
pre phase a when you think of all the
things that can go wrong it's not just
about again on the technical side it's
like okay we have this product launch
and maybe this isn't getting the revenue
we expect from it like what are the
other things we can do now if you have a
you know this organic team it can more
effectively technically adapt the
challenges that are faced but I would
say if you're really thinking deep when
you have the sharp minds at the very
beginning you can think I had about the
ways to pivot and I can say that I've
done that on our own and it was
precisely because of that level of
planning I have software interfaces in
the existing structure they'll let me
pivot without minimizing the expenses
for making additional software so I feel
that I'm very confident my team's
ability but every team will be different
yes and in that in that I understand
it's a bit early pretty big jump but you
know it depends on the team of folks do
you have and at a place like JPL I feel
very privileged to work with the people
that I work with yes let me see if I can
go back to that slide to just jog my
memory so one big thing that actually
has to do with the data acquisition
strategy is the first one which is the
psychometric test evaluation I need to
get personality test from people as a
part of the algorithm so i can do
matchmaking if anyone's done online
dating there tends to be some portion of
that now a part of the user experiences
making sure people feel satisfied a lot
of personality test says click a
question click a question click a
question but the part of my product is
there's going to be a lot more questions
that aren't personality I don't want to
bore the hell out of my users so I spent
a lot of time mitigating the risk of
people not wanting to use it because
they got bored of answering questions
and that's again an interdisciplinary
problem remembering a UI UX been the
psychometric test evaluation I evaluated
as many options as I found to ultimately
pick what I pics not so I was testing
for not just the science side am I
getting consistent results over making
multiple times does it fit with the
algorithm needs but also like getting
all my friends to use these various
examples did you like it so you sort of
do that preliminary tests to figure out
before you building anything else does
this sat do you think this satisfies the
requirement and of course it was still
failed but you mitigate that risk when
the risky came up in brainstorming
before you got to printing things that's
sort of the phase B type stuff so are
the critical technologies midshire i
don't know if that satisfies your
question but maybe I can try to give
some other ones later
what do you mean the transition
so I would I think that it is the role
of those that have the broadest view of
the information providing that it is
good information those are the ones who
will be making decisions now the
decision lies with what i would call if
you go to the JPL hierarchy you know
it's going to be these folks here are
making decisions about everything below
them on the technical aspect these guys
are making the language decisions in
some of the programmatic decisions for
these two different teams so they can
interface together with respect to the
plan that those guys decided on before
these guys even came into the picture so
I think it's a function of you know
Authority lies best with those that know
best what they are doing so boy that's
kind of a mouthful but I think
ultimately if you have a team of people
and you know if I know and this goes
back to maybe the other point I made
here or the role of management when they
have these meetings is to be humble look
I'm not the expert I will probably be
making a decision about this but my
decision is worthless and possibly very
dangerous if it is not well informed so
I know from the programmatic or the
system side what makes sense at the
global picture but I cannot decide that
in a good way unless I am fully
technically informed and I respect the
truth like the technical requirements
that i personally didn't draft and again
every team will be different and for my
experiences at JPL teams work very very
well in management systems that
engineers have a great deal technical
experience kind of like in a sense the
military a lot of generals or people who
become officers may have been on
commission from the beginning they spent
a lot of time knowing what it's like to
be a soldier so you know what it's like
is boots on the ground in in business
and other businesses perhaps that may
not necessarily be the case so it does
depend on the organization oh okay sorry
thank you so much guys
you